if you want to support this channel and
also get cool anime merch at the same
time like Keep Calm and ultra instinct
and your girl calls me senpai feel free
to check out our merch store link in the
description
[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and in this video we
will be talking about the real reason
why Goku keeps getting stronger and the
secret behind his ability to almost
always stay one step ahead of other
well-known fighters including Vegeta in
episode 126 of Dragon Ball super we
finally got a moment where Vegeta got to
shine in his battle against Topol and
this is the type of episode that Vegeta
fans have been waiting for for a long
time I can't tell you how many times
I've read frustrated comments on my
Dragon Ball super videos about how Akira
Toriyama hates Vegeta and that is why
Vegeta always plays second fiddle to
Goku and then of course Goku fans
respond by saying oh give it up already
Goku will always be better and so on
personally I like both Vegeta and Goku
and when I first watched Dragon Ball Z
my number one favorite character was
Future Trunks so I don't have a bias
towards either Goku or Vegeta but I do
have a theory for why Goku usually seems
to be one step ahead and why he keeps
getting stronger even when facing
impossible odds and I know that some of
you will say he keeps getting stronger
because the plot needs to stay
interesting and the story would be
boring if Gope who didn't get stronger
so that he could face stronger opponents
and of course that is true but I believe
that there is something important about
Goku's personality which makes it
possible for him to keep pushing the
limits of his power something that seems
like a weakness at first but ultimately
ends up being one of his biggest
strengths and it is this personality
trait that sets Goku apart from almost
all other fighters including Vegeta
even though Goku and Vegeta are both
incredibly powerful full-blooded Saiyans
and this secret of Goku's power is what
I will be talking about in this video if
you enjoy the Dragon Ball super content
on this channel and want to see more be
sure to leave a like to let me know and
if you are new don't forget to subscribe
and hit that notification valve we are
now posting daily anime content on
Twitter and Instagram so feel free to
follow us there at anime uproar now the
point
which I really started thinking about
both the strengths and weaknesses of
Goku's personality was the Future Trunks
saga in Dragon Ball super and especially
during the big showdown against Hamas
ooh in the future timeline as we all
know during this saga Goku does a number
of very foolish things including
forgetting to bring Senzu beans on one
occasion and forgetting to bring the
talisman that seals the mokuba on
another occasion now these are not just
small screw ups if goku hadn't forgotten
the talisman for the evil containment
wave or mokuba sama sue would likely
have been sealed inside it before he and
goku black got to fuse that one silly
mistake put everyone in the entire
timeline in danger and in the end the
timeline had to be erased by future Zeno
however it might never have come to that
point if Goku had brought the talisman
in the first place at another point
during this saga we learned that Goku
doesn't even know what kissing is
despite the fact that he has a wife and
two kids as silly as this is it all goes
to emphasize how innocent and naive
Goku's personality is in many ways Goku
is like a carefree child who is always
looking to have fun by fighting the
strongest possible opponents
unlike Goku most of the other characters
including Vegeta are far more mature and
serious and you will recall that while
training Goku and Vegeta Wiese mentions
that Vegeta is very strategic in battle
and he likes to think things through
rationally but this sometimes leads to
him overthinking things and that is why
it is harder for Vegeta to master ultra
instinct on the other hand Goku is much
more carefree when he fights which makes
it easier for him to act without
thinking and that is exactly what is
required for ultra instinct but the
drawback of Goku's approach is that he
sometimes becomes reckless and drops his
guard so how does this relate back to
Goku strength and the real reason why he
keeps getting stronger if we think back
to the battle against feuds imasu
everyone is shocked by the extent of
feuds amass lose power the master states
that his body is immortal and it can
infinitely increase its power even the
supreme Kai's agree that they have never
witnessed a power like this before
a power that combines immortality with
ultimate strength and for nearly all of
them the situation seems hopeless but
Goku doesn't agree when he sees how
incredibly strong fused the muscle is
Goku simply says all we gotta do is get
even stronger than that
this is Goku's innocence and childish
outlook on life coming through despite
how desperate the situation seems
despite the fact that logically all hope
seems lost
Goku refuses to accept this reality and
he simply says without thinking twice
that all he has to do is get even
stronger now we could say that goku is
just being stubborn here and we know
that vegeta is also stubborn and full of
Saiyan pride during the fight with the
master Vegeta says that Saiyans have no
limits and he fights bravely throughout
the whole fight but if we think back to
his past even Vegeta has moments where
he thinks that a situation is hopeless
because the enemy is simply too powerful
while facing off against super perfect
self back in Dragon Ball Z Vegeta
plainly states that he cannot make a
difference because cell is too strong
according to Vegeta cell has already won
and when he first comes face to face
with beerus sama at bulma's birthday
party on earth Vegeta is very
intimidated by the god of destruction
and he does his best not to anger him
and of course Vegeta doesn't want to
anger the god of destruction because he
believes that he wouldn't stand a chance
against him in battle and all of this
makes logical sense Vegeta is a
strategist he thinks things through and
he knows that according to common sense
he simply doesn't stand a chance against
opponents who are so much stronger than
him
but this is the crucial difference
between Vegeta and Goku Goku doesn't
care about logic or common sense
Goku's innocent and naive personality is
not limited by what is considered
reasonable or practical no matter who
the opponent is no matter how outmatched
Goku happens to be at any given time
Goku believes in himself or he believes
in
Gohan but Goku never gives up Vegeta is
more of a realist who looks at the facts
and makes a decision based on those
facts so if an opponent is far too
strong Vegeta sometimes comes to the
conclusion that there is no point in
fighting but Goku is not a realist he is
a fun-loving idealist who never lets
things like common sense or logic get in
the way of his goals throughout the
battle against fuse de mas Sousa mas who
keeps talking about how mortals have no
chance of beating him and how they
should just give up and what's a mas who
is saying here does make sense at first
glance sama su is a divine being he is
immortal and he has unlimited power
judging by those facts alone someone who
is a realist would conclude that there
is no realistic way of defeating fused
imasu but Goku doesn't care about what
is reasonable and what is realistic when
trunks and Vegeta are both incapacitated
by the masu Goku steps up with a savage
Kamehameha and pushes back some muscles
onslaught an epic Dragonball fashioned
Goku's personality can often be childish
and naive and this is clearly a weakness
in some ways because it leads them to do
foolish things like forget them of fuba
talisman but this carefree personality
is also Goku's greatest strengths it is
precisely this naive and innocent
outlook on life that allows Goku to defy
common sense to reject what other people
consider to be realistic and practical
Goku refuses to take no for an answer
Goku refuses to accept that he cannot
defeat an opponent just because that
opponent happens to be far more powerful
than him in this particular moment and
this unique personality trait is exactly
what allows Goku to do the impossible
and overcome every single obstacle
someone who is a very rational realistic
and pragmatic person will assess the
situation and if they feel that their
opponent is way out of their league they
will know that it's time to quit and
accept the fee but not Goku Goku is
carefree
childish and idealistic sometimes he is
downright reckless but it is this
recklessness that always puts
over the top when other more rational
fighters hesitate when they back down
and when they want to give up Goku steps
up
Goku refuses to accept the fee he keeps
fighting he keeps trying to get stronger
he keeps trying to tap into greater
levels of power against all odds and
that is why Goku stands out from the
crowd you miss 100% of the shots you
don't take
and people who have a very rational and
realistic personality will not take the
shot if they think that the odds are
almost impossible but Goku will take
that shot every single time he doesn't
know the meaning of the word impossible
and that is why he succeeds where others
fail in this sense Goku reminds me a lot
of my favorite anime character of all
time coming up from Gurren Lagann
kameena literally has a saying kick
reason to the curb and do the impossible
he is all about rejecting common sense
if common sense tells you to give up and
he believes in fighting against all odds
because nothing is truly impossible if
you believe in yourself
Goku's innocent and naive personality
can be a weakness at times as we've seen
throughout Dragon Ball when he makes
foolish mistakes that another character
would not make but Goku's personality
can also be his greatest strength
because it helps him persevere where
everyone else gives up and I really
appreciate this because I can actually
relate to this in my own personal life
most practical and realistic people will
never decide to become youtubers because
it takes such a long time for a YouTube
channel to grow and actually become
successful if it ever becomes successful
at all because on YouTube nothing is
guaranteed to grow a channel you have to
put in countless of hours of work even
though you aren't earning any money and
it takes quite a while for a channel to
go from nothing to actually earning
money on YouTube someone who is a
realist and a pragmatist would probably
pick any other job over YouTube because
they don't want to work hard for free
when they could find a job that will
start paying them right away as soon as
they start working to stick it out as a
youtuber when you're starting off with
nothing you have to be an idealist and
you have to be someone who doesn't take
no for
answer just like Goku and in this sense
I can definitely say that Goku despite
sometimes having a naive nature is one
of my anime inspiration but that is my
theory for why Goku's unique personality
allows him to keep getting stronger
against all odds let me know what you
guys think about Goku's personality and
whether you agree that his personality
plays a crucial role in his ability to
keep getting stronger if you enjoyed
this video and want to see more be sure
to leave a like to let me know if you
are new don't forget to subscribe and
hit that notification bell and if you
happen to be an artist that makes
high-quality fan art for Dragon Ball and
other anime like attack on Titan my hero
academia or seven deadly sins and if you
would like to have your fan art featured
in one of our videos you can contact us
through Twitter or Instagram at Anime
uproar if we can use your fan art in the
video or for a thumbnail we will include
a link to your social media in the
description as always thank you all so
much for watching thank you for all the
support and until next time see ya space
cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]